your children are experiencing allergies
and asthma symptoms optimum care lung
and allergy care the sponsors of this
segment are here to help
dr vernouya welcome back
thank you
man thank you for having me back rocky
oh yeah of course i'm sure people are
keeping you busy over there especially
with the allergies going on in the air
in vegas right now
oh yes it's that time of the year it is
that time but we're talking about
allergies and asthma for children in
particular so let's start with asthma
let's define that for everybody
sure well there's so many kinds of
asthma
but the sixty percent of asthma
depending on who you read is allergic
asthma and asthma this is described as
inflammation meaning swelling
and accumulation of mucus in the airways
which causes it to constrict or do
narrow
causing symptoms of difficulty of
breathing wheezing coughing and
sometimes chest tightness
okay and are allergies and asthma do
they go together
are they related to two-thirds of the
time they do meaning if you have
allergies you are three times more than
likely to develop asthma at any time so
that's how they are related because the
inflammation in from your nose and your
upper airways has a direct relationship
to the inflammation in your lower
airways which is what asthma is
okay and what can trigger asthma in
children
there's so many triggers and everybody's
asthma is very unique to that person but
the most common triggers include when
you get sick so respiratory tract
infections
exposure to the things that you're
allergic to or sometimes irritants like
smoke
and sometimes very vigorous activity
and of course during this time
respiratory illness like kobit
could potentially affect that as well um
what are what are the symptoms of asthma
for children what do they see first
the most common symptoms again and these
are very specific to the person
some people experience wheezing some
people have difficulty of breathing some
experience chest tightness and others
have just a
cough that leads to difficulty breathing
yeah it's so it's so difficult to deal
with especially for children who haven't
fully developed yet right um what are
what are the treatments
that children can have for asthma
the treatment for asthma will consist of
two classes one is a rescue meaning you
take this medication when you have a
problem it's like taking tylenol for
fever it's called albuterol it opens up
your airways momentarily and then the
the uh the rest is called controller
medications these are medicines that you
take every day to control your asthma so
that the chances of you needing your
rescue will decrease
but the mo but one of the most important
things is that together with asthma
medications you should also control your
allergies because that is directly
related to your asthma so make sure you
take care of those allergies first and
foremost if you're seeing them and
hopefully that can prevent the asthma
correct okay we got it well thank you so
much dr vernoya
thanks again rocky all right soon
all right thank you optim care lung and
allergy care for sponsoring this segment
they have locations across southern
nevada give them a call at 702-724-8844